flooding devastation
and disease what could
all these awful things have in common
rain and lots of it
we're not talking april showers here
so imagine a downpour lasting
not for a few hours or even days
instead imagine 365 days of
non-stop rain
how would that rain affect the earth
how would it affect your health
and could it even affect how we
breathe this is what if
and here's what would happen if it
rained every day for a year
rain is vital for life on earth the
plants
and animals need it we need it too
for drinking water and to grow crops
but too much of a good thing can
tip the balance and climate data shows
that
the amount of torrential rain is
increasing
a study from the university of
saskatchewan found that
worldwide between 2004 and 2013
there were seven percent more extreme
bouts of heavy rain
and in europe and asia extreme rains
increased by 8.6
and from 1980 to 2009
rain caused floods that killed more than
half a million people
so if it were to rain non-stop for a
year
it could have serious consequences for
everything on earth
but what's causing this increase
in torrential rains have you ever
wondered
how much water is up in the sky
well if all the water in the atmosphere
suddenly fell to earth it would cover
the entire surface
and be two and a half centimeters deep
that would be 37 and a half million
billion gallons of water vapor falling
on our planet
now imagine that rain is constantly
falling
in a never-ending downpour of epic
proportions
well we know it's going to flood but
just how bad would it get
well if you like going to the beach or
tropical islands the daily rains could
ruin your holidays
islands would be affected first they'd
be lost to the sea
pretty quickly and places like the
netherlands and europe
would face dire consequences as the
water level rises
there's a good chance that they would be
completely underwater
the usual protocol during a flood is to
go
to higher ground it's safer than
low-lying areas
but there's a major issue if you go
higher up too
water avalanches all that rain
could cause landslides mudslides and
waterfalls so those areas would
not exactly be safe either the thing is
the initial flooding and mountain perils
would
just be the start of our problems have
you thought about
how all that rain might affect your
health
it might be easy to overlook your
physical and mental
well-being if never-ending rain is
pouring down outside but
health-wise it's a serious problem to
deal with
you might think that there would be
plenty of water to drink but
we'd have to collect that water
carefully
it would be easy for our reservoirs and
water systems
to be flooded with pollutants from waste
and debris
and that would cause disease to spread
rapidly
and don't forget there ain't no sunshine
when it rains hard
we all need vitamin d and the easiest
way to get it
is from sunlight but if it rains
all day every day i guess we'll just
need to buy vitamins instead
and people could start suffering from
depression due to the lack of sunlight
it's a real downer so there will be
flooding
and disease but i bet you didn't even
think what would happen to the
air did you another consequence of the
persistent rain
would be a severe lack of oxygen for us
to breathe
healthy soil contains oxygen but with so
much
water in it there would be much less
room for
oxygen water erosion would expose roots
and
make trees and plants unstable
and to top it all off our crops would be
wiped out
they'd drown and that could be the nail
in the coffin for
humanity so if the starvation doesn't
get you
the low oxygen levels probably will yeah
it's not a great forecast if it rains
every day for a year
but if it happens is there anything we
could do
well there are places on earth that get
a huge amount of rain
let's take a look at the wettest place
on earth
it's a state in india called meghalaya
especially the town of mousenram
its lush green rainforests help convert
carbon dioxide
back into breathable oxygen each year
it receives a staggering 12 meters of
rainfall
and people have managed to thrive there
for hundreds of years
one of their most ingenious solutions is
building
living bridges they're made from the
rubber trees in the rain forest
once constructed they can live for 500
years
or longer so there is hope for us in
such a sudden scenario but interestingly
and maybe sadly mega leia
and other super wet areas are drying out
and it looks like it's being caused by
global warming
but hold on global warming is supposed
to be
causing more rain right unfortunately
climate change is a complex issue
it's a vicious cycle of mistreating our
planet
and environmental issues we don't fully
understand
but we do know that global warming is
affecting our world in various ways
in the case of meghalaya and many other
places around the world
we know that climate change is causing
droughts
monsoons are still happening but with
less rainfall
and there's deforestation
we now know that it can affect weather
patterns
locally and globally
so if it rained every day for a year
even though it's improbable there's
something we can learn from all this
we live in a beautiful world with all
its animals and plants but
we could be changing our world in ways
that could spiral
out of our control and hey i wouldn't
want that
how about you it gets me thinking
if we got all that rain what
would happen to our power systems
what if earth lost power for
seven days well that's a story
for another what if